so I'm glad that we ended on that last
piece showing the sort of emotional
control of the dress because where I
want to take this talk is more the
mundane everyday kind of wearables that
everyday people would buy Best Buy
etcetera and while there's a lot of
discussion of things like form factor
and the aesthetics what I want to focus
on is what I'm calling here a wearable
self-regulation which is does resonate
in this this last piece of the same so
as Leila mentioned in the context of MIT
as I would suspect most of us in this
room are well aware of wearables have
this very rich history here's just two
images I'm not even going to name all
the people up here many of these early
wearables take the form of backpack
mounted computers head gear glasses
webcams and a lot of them have the
function of enhancing your ability to
see to know to record and sometimes to
transcend the material world and turn
one into a kind of cyborg
I'm not going to exhaustively go through
this but it's one of the main timelines
you can find of wearables MIT figures
prominently and here we have coming up
two examples by Steve Mann for example
his wearable backpack camera and later
webcam and then on to some of the more
mass-market the iPod etcetera products
were familiar with and it ends here in
2014 the year of the wearable its
christened and the backstory to the year
of the wearable is actually the year
before 2013 which was christened by
Forbes after the Consumer Electronics
Show in 2000 2013 the year of the
quantified self and this of course is a
reference to the now international group
quantified self or qf started by two
editors at Wired magazine here are some
of the stories that have been done
around
yes and as you can see this is a
community that ascribes to this quest
for self-knowledge self-knowledge
through numbers as in the tagline this
is very much an ethical project in the
sense that numerical metrics self
quantification self experimentation and
statistical correlation becomes a kind
of means to the good life to figure out
what is an ethical life to live how do I
want to live and be in the world and
foremost in QF I would say that
wearables are secondary in the sense
that they are a means to the numbers
through which you can know yourself so
front and center is the ethical project
here and popular media has seen the rise
of a kind of visual trope of the
quantified person whose rigged up with
all of this sensory laden wearables as
you see here just three examples just
sort of giving you this for the
visuality of it here are more cartoon
like animations but also bring us closer
to the terrain of the everyday guy like
the the two at the end there and these
these convey a sense of the body being
augmented and added to not only to
increase human insight and knowledge but
also to expand human reach and
capacities so these are kind of these
images are kind of in line with the MIT
cyborg Ian's vision and the guys
standing on the roof
but I want to suggest that there's a
different trajectory to wearables and
this is a trajectory that's become
salient recently and very connected to
the digital in the extension of digital
tools to to the masses so to speak and
this trajectory leads to everyday
consumer technologies that are not
primarily designed to help us optimize
or enhance or surpass ourselves in the
material world but to help us cope with
our existential fallibilities in
material environments that in many ways
challenge our flourishing so these kind
of wearables are designed I would say no
matter how they're sometimes marketed if
you really look underneath that and
sometimes directly in the marketing and
the red
of it they're designed primarily to help
us maintain cope deal abide with
everyday life here's just a smattering
of the kinds of technologies out there
and this has happened to sort of
bringing to the mass market of the
vision of quantified self has happened
through so-called
Cointreau fingers who started attending
qsr meetings and then making startups
etc and most notably when we think of
this kind of mass-market wearable
technology we think the Fitbit Apple
watch etc and at first I've been
tracking this since around 2009-2010 and
at first the the know yourself logic of
qf was simply ported over into the
mainstream the contra producer took that
out and brought it into the
advertisements and into the technology
providing people with a lot of
information about themselves but that
didn't work so well and it was a whole
lot of discussion about that and I would
go to the Consumer Electronics Show and
there would be these really polemical
panels like what are we going to do were
challenged how can we make this work
because it seemed that the mass markets
again so to speak
didn't have the time the resources are
really even the desire to embark on this
kind of ethical project so the language
and logic of design shifted in degrees
away from knowing yourself towards the
device knowing you and so you see that
just in one of many ads I could have put
up here this is for the Samsung
wristband which tells us the device can
know me better than I know myself and
can help me be a better human so
absolutely in this sentence we see
preserved the ethical project of
becoming a better human living a more
fulfilling life however that's happening
through a device that knows you better
than you know yourself that's that's a
significant step in this direction that
I'm heading in and as we'll see in the
rest of my comments there have been
further steps that go go beyond this
even away from knowledge altogether
towards action ability which is a word
you hear a lot in what
by wearable designers and Serta
frictionless guidance rather than
knowledge and this guidance tends to
happen at a really basic material
register for example the remote
rudimentary aspects of bodily existence
that I have put up here so stepping
sitting standing sipping chewing
breathing so things you learn to do
mostly when you're an infant so what
I'll do next is take you on a whirlwind
tour through some of the products that
address these areas and I hope you'll
see in the examples wearables are not
simply a kind of passive casing for
digital logics
but they have become a buzzing tapping
vibrating material the digital is
embedded in the material and vice versa
in these examples and I will show some
video clips and I'm going to start with
this early video from Fitbit which is
the common kind of Fitbit is sort of a
metonym for consumer wearables that's
how I explain my project to people like
Fitbit and they say okay I get it so
here we could just get the sound up this
is not all talk over it people are going
about their lives there's this kind of
digital overlay we get the sense that we
can just play in the backyard and trust
the device we're wearing to capture the
information we're generating so that we
don't have to monitor or track ourselves
so calories burned distance covered
duration of activity it's all here in
this dashboard being taken care of us I
love this scene he pauses it's this
existential moment Metro versus walking
and then he makes this decision he sets
out on the pathway he shares it with his
friends and he's just feeling great I
also love this part of the ad because
you see in concentric rings around the
feet this kind of otherwise invisible
data exhausts that you're giving off
that's radiating out and that has this
value that is being captured and it ends
you know I said here we're looking at
stepping but it ends up in bed and it
says we can track even when you are not
moving and asleep
and so on that note let's look now at
stillness here in the case of standing
we'll get to sitting a little later so a
lot of wearables focus primarily on
bodily stillness how you hold yourself
your posture and helping you maintain
proper posture
this is LUMO lift technology and it
corrects your posture through vibration
here's what you read in the product
literature through the app you can
control when you're buzzed how you're
buzzed and even how intensely it buzzes
which sounds a little erotic but here
I'm not sure whether we can have sound
make the magnetic sensor worn like a
clap or lapel pin on your upper body
either as jewelry or hidden under your
clothes lips tracks your body positions
and movements when you slouch or close
off your body the LUMO lift provides a
gentle vibrations to remind you to keep
your shoulders down and back
and head lifted lift also connects to an
app that tracks your posture giving you
gentle nudges to help you improve over
time so there's definitely a heavy kind
of coaching element here but still
information being imparted now we look
at sipping and there's so many of these
out there and I find most of them so
ugly that I just put a prototype drawing
up here but hydration another mundane
yet vital human action part of our daily
subsistence this is the focus of many of
these kind of gadgets they keep track of
how much liquid is consumed and then
they convey it to your smartphone and
your smartphone has a program that will
alert you if you're not hydrated enough
of course according to the algorithm so
I'm not focusing on that so much in this
talk but of course the algorithm is
really important here in determining
what shape guidance should take so some
of these will adjust your goals based on
temperature humidity and provide
feedback in various kind of visual and
haptic ways so they may vibrate change
color blink lights and of course the
smartphone notification so I count the
as wearables in the sense that they're
meant to be carried around all day and
accompany you so we don't need sound on
this one but here it shows you know like
it's morning and you should be waking up
with this in your hand and you should
keep it in your hand and you take the
subway walk down the street and it's
really part of your outfit now it's
night time and still you're wearing and
it goes on and on
chewing okay so stepping sipping sitting
standing here's the happy fork and this
meant this is designed to intervene it's
a smart utensil in the habit of feeding
and it monitors and records the length
of each meal the number of fork servings
per meal and the time between the
servings so if shorter than 10 seconds
as we'll see it will oscillate so that
the eater knows to slow down and so
years 2 is a screen you'll see you're
advised I'm reading from the product
literature you're advised to take about
10 to 20 choose we trigger the alarm by
eating too fast don't panic set the fork
down at the side of the plate and wait
until the light turns green again
signaling that it is safe to take
another bite so this is presented as an
everyday technology that really in
effect turned something as routine as
human as basic as material as a single
bite of food into a matter of potential
danger and we'll come back to this theme
of danger and so the Company recommends
of course you know despite this idea of
the basket on the table where you put
your phone away most of the ads show
mostly women with their forks their
phones and their food it's not such a
social thing so as you eat you know you
feed yourself and your data is then fed
back to you and it's this this little
loop and all we don't need the sound
here on this is just to show you it
vibrates and you eat too fast so as
you're eating it oops too fast then
you're logging and you're looking at
your metrics so there's some
self-reflection here there's some
self-knowledge
again the erotics of this are there too
for somebody else to talk about and then
he or she does well great timing so
really I see this as a kind of techno
dressage or sort of algorithmic
entrainment for eating that is happening
and just this final example of breathing
right the most elemental you could say
aspect of existence this is also a
technology of entrainment it's called
the spire and it helps you regulate your
breath and by extension your stress
levels so it alerts you when your
respiration becomes shallow erratic or
too fast for instance you're in a tense
streak or time for breath etc so again
as your is your actions and States are
fed into the data streams the data
streams are fed back into your actions
and States and become a part of your
aspect the material aspect of your
experience and another version of this
sort of takes on both posture and breath
so this is more focused on sitting this
is posture correcting wearables let me
play this again we don't need the sound
another author has recently written on
this that these these technologies are
imagined as this is when she's not
wearing it right imagined as active
agents as coaches and trainers who call
users to attention when slouching is
detected so it really is seen as a kind
of maybe we will put sound on now heart
rate increases along with stress
hormones like adrenaline and cortisol so
we've designed prana to counter these
unhealthy trends product consists of
multiple accelerometers dance algorithms
and a low-energy Bluetooth connection to
a smartphone all these work together to
track both your breathing and posture
from just a single location on your
waist and when you're breathing shows
signs of stress or your posture is poor
Ron and gently notifies you
here's the buzzing
[Music]
sit upright take a big belly breath and
refocus on your body for a month okay so
you get the idea
so let's step back for a moment now you
know what is an anthropologist of
technology to make of all of this as a
mode of self-regulation you know in
which chewing and sitting have become
dangerous things in the environment
there's this idea that the environment
is hostile and we are talking here about
you know there's been laughing these are
mundane consumer landscapes that are
very unlike refugee camps very unlike
outer space both of these things you
know which we've heard a little bit
about will hear more about at this
gathering but nonetheless there's a big
market around this and these
environments are figured as toxic choice
architecture that really hobbles our
ability to thrive and this technology
sort of steps on the scene to help us
with that the cells of self-tracking are
understood by those who are invested in
wearable technology to be choosing
agents agents of the market and that
their well-being depends on the market
choices that they make and when those
choices sort of slide away from being
savvy and vigilant they're going to be
harmful and the idea is that although
that's the case that we need to be savvy
and vigilant we just can't we are
fallible humans we lack the knowledge we
nacked lack the foresight the reef the
resources etc to navigate this abundance
of potential choice in this kind of mall
mall of life and so the wearable tech
industry very consciously banks on that
double insecurity so the customers they
imagine are really unsure whether to
trust their own senses and desires and
bodily intuitions as they move about the
world making these basic material
choices of when and what to eat and
drink how much to move or rest how slow
or fast to breathe and the idea is that
the technology can help us take the
guesswork out of those challenges and on
the one hand they are acting as a kind
of digital compass that's providing us
information
helping us navigate modern life in this
dashboard kind of fashion to help kind
of weave our way through this
confounding landscape with a smile on
our face because we feel like we know
what to do how to manage our lifestyle
so you can consult in these three images
on the wrist on a pendant on the screen
and get this guidance on these prosaic
decisions about how much to move hydrate
eat and sleep but increasingly and this
is what I want to end up on they're
designed not just to offer information
that we can take in and use to reflect
on ourselves in this ethical project but
to act as one designer put it quote in
the fashion of a thermostat so the idea
is that mass-market track is tracking
technology unlike the kind that might
appeal to the geeks or the engineers
needs to do more than just give
information and self knowledge on our
micro rhythms and our little micro
choices that it needs to steer those
choices through material interventions
and prompts like taps and buzzes and
I've been calling this micro nudges I'm
referring back to Nicholas is opening
remarks I'd say this is an attempt to
get us to experience our bits it and if
it's not exactly that the medium is the
message
certainly it's that the message is
intimately folded into the medium and
that the message has material matter to
it and so the ideas for devices to kind
of serve as these caring thermostats who
will not just for our own good and that
will know us better than we know
ourselves know in advance what we need
and then quote give actionable updates
before you even need to ask
as one pundit puts it and that
particular person as Leslie's a leader
says I don't want to track I want it to
be done for me insert a chip in my mouth
have it record the calories that would
be heard you know the holy grail of
tracking for her and so this is imagined
really as a kind of care a kind of
delegating of the tedious labor of self
care and self-regulation in a world that
we can't cope with on our own and on
this note of
hair I want to end up with the final
example I'll give which is the device
called mother which almost too nicely
captures this externalization of
responsibility on to technology whatever
you want whenever you want it's sort of
the all-knowing mother really the mother
of the infant right who's there before
the infant even knows they're hungry and
so if before it was about know thyself
now it's about here if you can read
mother knows everything
and this device isn't exactly wearable
but it uses sensors called motion
cookies and you can put them on
different things and on yourself and
then they will intercede to quench your
thirst before you might know that you
need to drink something I need to drink
more water it helps me concentrate I fix
the sensor to the bottle which then
you're holding it encourages me to drink
when you forget can remind you to take
your pills it can wake you up in the
morning and this is the final video
segmental play and we can have sound
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay so we've moved on my 20 minutes are
almost up so I'll wrap up we've moved on
from this strict definition of wearables
as I said but I think it really captures
the kind of material digital care that's
at stake in this mode of self-regulation
and when you follow this line of
wearable technology versus the kind of
strategic you know the shoe that cheats
the roulette game or the self optimizing
self expanding unconstrained human
vision that people like Mann and others
had you you end up quite far from the
sort of cyborg that those visions
conjure up these wearables are quite
different they're focusing as I said on
the basic material aspects of life and I
think the selves who are wearing them
are also quite different
these are selves who are not out to
optimize or expand but really to
maintain and to cope in this world that
they are materially bound to but have
difficulty navigating so in a way this
is outsourcing in some sense the ethical
project to digital technology and had I
had more time and maybe in the QA it can
come up just very quickly
alternative future for wearables you
know I don't want to end up on a totally
individualizing privatising note because
there are ways that people have come up
with and are beginning to increasingly
of not using these to just focus on
yourself and sidestep systemic reform
like let's regulate the food industry
etc but to collectively change the
environment in which we live so we see
around the world wearing what individual
why of what wearable devices on your
body but crowdsourcing it to monitor
pollution and so there's all sorts of
little dongles and things where you can
then crowdsource the data and presumably
use this for policy change so I'll end
there thank you
you